10h le relais des Restos du cœur de
trappe est en pleine préparation c'est
le début de la campagne d'hiver il faut
trier organiser et disposer les aliments
pour faciliter la distribution aux
familles conserves pâtes farines sucre
légumes pour l'instant attrape les
stocks sont là mais la crainte du manque
n'est pas loin pour l'instant on y
arrive encore mais ns ramasse magasin on
travaille avec des magasin baisse quand
même pas mal et du coup ça oblige les
restaux du cœur à acheter de en plus de
produits et effectivement on s'attend à
un moment donné à ce que les restaux
n'arrivent plus à acheter ça leur coûte
très cher et on sera obligé d'impacter
ça sur les familles que l'on accueille
attrape 500 familles se sont inscrites
pour cet hiver selon Olga c'est un
chiffre déjà conséquent pour un début de
campagne en raison également de
l'inflation elle a vu une quarantaine de
nouvelles familles venir s'inscrire
cette année une situation qui se reflète
au niveau départemental il y a deux
choses il y a effectivement on va être
obligé avec les décisions du National de
refuser des familles puisqu'ils vont
plus rentrer dans dans notre barê et ça
c'est quand même toujours quelque chose
de difficile pour les bénévoles de
devoir dire non devoir dire aux familles
B on peut vous aider sur d'autres choses
mais pas sur l'aide alimentaire et
puisquon ne sait pas c'est effectivement
quel pourcentage de nouvelles familles
on va voir arriver dans les ivelines les
restos du cœur ont constaté une
aggravation de la précarité et une forte
augmentation du nombre de personnes
accueillies entre 2022 et 2023 plus de
2,5 millions de repas ont été distribués
c'est 600000 repas de plus et pour cet
hiver le doute persiste concernant
l'augmentation du nombre de
bénéficiaires dans ce relais attrape la
file d'attente est longue ça fait 6 mois
que que je viens ici parce qu'on arrive
pas en fait avec qu enfants et je
travaille pas et c'est pas facile c'est
très difficile pour moi donc là je
touche que enfin les allocations
handicapé et puis voilà donc j'arrive
pas avec j'ai trois enfants avec le
loyer les charges et tout c'est vraiment
difficile c'est très difficile ça a
beaucoup changé hein depuis l'arrivée du
covid et puis voilà quoi donc ça a tout
changé je suis sans papier euh j'ai
besoin d'aide je travaille mais tu sais
avec
le loyer tout ça c'est trop cher cette
39e campagne des Restos du cœur s'ouvre
ainsi sur de grandes incertitudes autour
des chiffres de fréquentation les
premières tendances laissent à penser
que la vague ne faiblit pour faire face
l'association a demandé au gouvernement
un coup de pouce de 50 millions d'euros
supplémentaires